Trump trounced Hillary Clinton in 2016
right here in Texas and it's been a
solidly red state and I've got about it
but there are Suns in recent years that
counties are turning more blue Democrats
now believe Texas is within reach that
they could deprive Trump of a victory in
2020 joining me now with some answers I
love how you just appeared out of there
like that it's Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo who's been on the ground
with me in Texas great reporting by the
way from the border thank you how
realistic is it that the Democrats could
flip the stick what Laura look since
we've been here we've seen a great deal
that this state is no doubt changing now
the biggest population centers are the
cities as a snapshot of what's happening
here in Denton County which is north of
Dallas Ted Cruz won by 32 points in 2012
in 2016 Trump won there by 20 points but
in 2018 Cruz won re-election by only 7
points the political landscape here is
clearly shifting for more insight I
spoke with Texas voters and Mark Jones
he's a political science professor at
Rice University's Baker Institute I
asked Jones why Democrats believe they
can flip Texas for the first time since
the 1970s demographics are changing in
Texas is becoming bluer with a less
Anglo and more northern population and
also Donald Trump who is a real
liability for Texas Republicans it's
becoming more Latino and more
asian-american and we're seeing more
people move from the north here and
that's having a transformation on Texas
politics causing them to vote a little
more Democratic does Texas go blue in
2020
I don't think Texas will go blue in 2020
and less perhaps Joe Biden is the
candidate it's going to be a pivotal
election here in Texas in 2020 not just
for us Texans but for the entire nation
it looks like the demographics of the
suburbs around places like Houston are
changing and some are saying Texas could
flip blue as a result if Joe Biden and
Donald Trump were on the ticket who
would you vote for who do you think
would win this area Donald Donald Trump
will definitely still win I think
there's definitely a lot of people that
are that are
from other parts of the country that are
definitely changing our demographics in
the in the Greater Houston area and
Texas in general but I feel like there's
too much success from Donald Trump you
can't you can't argue with success you
got a boat for Biden why would you do it
because I think Trump even with this
economy roaring I don't care for you a
native Texan no where'd you come where
you from I'm from Kansas City
I don't think the demographics have
changed that much since the last
election which way do you think the
stable
truck why because Texas is those always
be Republican
Laura's you heard from that lady from
Kansas City the state is changing
demographically one of every ten Texas
residents did not live here in 2012 and
this state has six of the ten fastest
growing counties in the country for the
GOP to hold this state they're gonna
have to pound the outer suburbs in these
big urban areas 38 electoral votes hang
in the balance Laura look when bado came
along and he lost by only two or three
points they thought this is our
opportunity we'll see if that population
growth all the bleed California is
having they're all coming into Texas so
they're coming into this great economy
in Texas they want to wreck it who wants
to do that you get the fall all right
let's get off let's see if the camera
push let's get all there we go okay all
right I'll call right now push I'll see
you later bye